et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
didier maïsto président de sud radio
bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à ses côtés
jean sébastien ferjou fondateur
d'atlantico merci à vous d'être là
également un week end à nouveau marquée
par plusieurs violence on en parlera que
ça soit du côté voilà de l'exécutif
emmanuel macron pris pour cible du côté
également des manifestants de la police
un manifestant frapper au sol par un
policier samedi lors d'une manifestation
parisienne de gilet jaune il sera jugé
ultérieurement pour violences sur des
policiers
les policiers eux mêmes portent plainte
ce qu'il est toujours possible didier
maïsto avons l'honneur vous avez suivi
toutes ces manifestations depuis le
début est ce qu'il est toujours possible
de manifester sans danger dans notre
pays aujourd'hui
malheureusement la réponse est dans la
question on voit que ça devient de plus
en plus difficile on voit qu'il ya une
escalade de la violence
on l'a connu avec les gilet jaune parce
que on a vu au bout de assez vite
d'ailleurs dès l'acte 2 de l'acte iii
qui atteint son paroxysme et puis après
cette violence a été instrumentalisé par
le pouvoir au plus qu'à l'acte iii
l'acte iii ils ont été dépassés ensuite
ils ont essayé de de l'instrumentaliser
en désignant les manifestants comme
étant eux mêmes des gens violents en
faction séditieux assoiffés de sang et
demi de la république et de la france
homophobe raciste antisémite j'en passe
et des meilleurs et donc sa stratégie de
la tension a continué ça s'est poursuivi
avec les grèves avec les grévistes
hélas la france remarque aujourd'hui que
ce n'est pas simplement dévolu au gilet
jaune un traitement spécial mais qu'en
fait tout mouvement de manifestations
toute contestation l'a vu aujourd'hui et
ce matin avec les avocats et des gardes
à vue
arbitraire des arrestations des
interpellations il devient très
difficile dans notre pays de manifester
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement ce
régime
c est un secret pour personne ne tire
est libre ou la paix c'est un régime
c'est un régime qui ne tient plus que
par la police puisque il ya une absence
de discussion il ya un malentendu
profond entre le peuple et ses reprises
ses représentants désignés ou appelons
les les représentants est donc
aujourd'hui quand vous avez comme ça un
exécutif qui ne tient que par les forces
de l'ordre avec une stratégie de la
tension ça ne peut que mal se finir donc
il est urgent effectivement que le
président la république prenne une
décision politique dissolution
référendum certains disent démission
n'aurait pas jusque là mais une décision
politique parce qu'on voit semaine après
semaine quand on tournait au coeur des
manifs et effectivement je chine depuis
annonce qu' il ya une escalade de la
violence que que les manifestations
soient déclarés pas déclaré on a
toujours la même stratégie du nas âge du
tabassage est effectivement aussi des
manifestants il faut pas l'ignorer qui
se radicalise jean sébastien ferjou déjà
sur le diagnostic on va rentrer un peu
plus dans les détails est prêt mais sur
le diagnostic de votre voisin je crois
qu'il ya incontestablement une stratégie
de la tension après à la question
première que vous poser est ce qu'on
peut manifester sont en danger dans ce
pays ça dépend des manifestations enfin
plus exactement ça dépend de la cause
les démarches pour le climat la
manifestation contre l'islamophobie
pardon n'a pas été entachée de violences
non plus mais c'est vrai qu
incontestablement il ya une stratégie de
la tension après peut être là où je
mettrais un bémol par rapport à la
vision quant à didier maïsto c'est que
ce n'est pas ce gouvernement là qu'a
inventé la violence ni la violence des
manifestations ni peut-être la violence
politique
le climat de violence politique existe
dans ce pays je pense que les
démocraties occidentales dans leur
ensemble vivent une crise de défiance et
que le vrai échec de même macron et que
sa promesse était de réenchanter en
quelque sorte justement en tout cas de
nous faire sortir collectivement de
cette crise de défiance très clairement
il n'y est pas parvenu il n'est pas le
seul à être responsables de cet état de
fait parce que je pense qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment d'opposition qui arrive à
s'imposer à se dégager je passe une
dissolution nous permettrait peut-être
aurait-il intérêt à le faire
politiquement ça c'est une autre
question
mais je vois personne en l'état qui est
de majorité je pense que c'est pas
négligeable parce que la crise elle se
construit aussi par rapport à ça le
monopole de la violence légitime encore
faut-il que vous soyez perçu comme
légitime et on voit que de plus en plus
les gouvernements ne sont plus perçus
comme légitime et que en face il ya des
gens alors on peut ne pas être perçu
comme légitime par des manifestants qui
resterait parfaitement pacifique au
moment de la manif pour tous notamment
des manifestants étaient extrêmement
pacifique ce qui n'a pas empêché
d'ailleurs c'était un nouveau
quinquennat une répression n'ont pas
vraiment policière en tout cas
judiciaire assez sévères vis-à-vis des
veilleurs notamment donc comme je vous
le dis ça s'inscrit dans une histoire
mais là où il ya une véritable
responsabilité là dessus je rejoins
vraiment didier maïsto c'est sur ce
mélange de stratégie et probablement
d'incompétence vous savez la vieille
phrase quand on vous propose une
explication complotistes entre pas entre
le complotisme et l'incompétence
privilégiez toujours en premier lieu
l'incompétent je pense qu'il ya de ça
cela que le préfet de police précédent
ne savait pas bien géré je pense que
monsieur castetner comme ministre de
l'intérieur ne sait pas bien c'est un
mélange de stratégie parce que ils ont
joué à la tension pour que ce soit
clivant et pour que l'opinion se
retourne en leur faveur
enfin en la faveur du gouvernement à
force de voir ces violences là ça un peu
marcher d'ailleurs au moment
gilet jaune mais il ya aussi un vrai un
vrai problème en matière de maintien de
l'ordre en cette ère de maîtrise de
maintien de l'ordre
et en plus puisque ces mouvements durs
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de policiers qui
malheureusement sont envoyés sur la
ligne de front en quelque sorte en
n'étant pas assez formés et mal encadré
donc c'est un espèce de cocktail
explosif
voilà effectivement le bémol étant
peut-être gouvernement des panneaux ses
propres et s'initier même qui se
succèdent sur ce plateau on voit
expliqué que la formation est très
compliqué ils ont pas eu le temps d'être
formés et c'est majeur en intervenant
c'est absolument majeur les gens ne se
rendent pas compte sur l'impression
quatre policiers c'est resté là non
savoir ne pas réagir enfin ça va enfin
même les tactiques d'occupation d'une
rue ou pour empêcher la progression d'un
mouvement
c'est absolument c'est absolument majeur
et effectivement il ya des policiers qui
ne sont pas formés aujourd'hui marine le
pen et aux mille efforts du parti
socialiste demande clairement le départ
du préfet l'helmand le préfet de police
de paris est ce que c'est l'une des
solutions à l'heure des mea culpa de
christophe castaner d'un côté d'emmanuel
macron qui commande qui parle de
déontologie bien soyons clairs on peut
toujours s'attaquer aux lampistes en
réalité effectivement quand il y avait
l'ancien préfet de police de paris où il
avait été jugé par par ce pouvoir trop
mou trop laxiste et trop permissive et
quand il avait émis des petits bémols
justement quant à l'utilisation dlb des
par exemple ou dans la stratégie de
maintien de l'ordre
c'était un secret là aussi de
polichinelle un mois avant pendant les
milieux informés on savait que monsieur
l'allemand allait être nommé
donc aujourd'hui monsieur l'allemand il
applique la politique qui lui et qui lui
est dicté par l'elysée est d'ailleurs
dans ses voeux à la presse c'est ce qu'a
dit tout à fait manuel macron il a dit
qu'il ne faiblit pas face
et puis tout tous les éléments de
langage vous l'avez vu encore tout ce
week-end que ce soit des ministres et
secrétaires d'état des députés de la
république en marche tout le monde va
dans ce sens alors il pousse des cris
d'orfraie quand vous avez 20 personnes
qui rentrent en chantant dans la cfdt
c'est pas bien
qui ment d'envahir un local syndical
enfin il ya quand même eu leur aplomb
rappelons le dans sa l'excellent travail
de david dufresne 900 signalements de
décès vingt-cinq personnes éborgné cinq
mains arrachées 385e blessures à la tête
c'est pas du détail et que encore une
fois à m'inquiéter dans mon adn c'était
plutôt au départ d'être pour les forces
de l'ordre légal nice etc
j'ai voulu aller voir venividivici j'ai
vu effectivement je ne peux qu j'ai
vaincu j'ai vaincu en tout cas la langue
de bois c'est déjà ce que vous nous
dites parce que vu de l'extérieur c'est
vrai qu'on peut se poser la question on
lit aussi quelques papiers parce qu'on
parle toujours de l'instrumentalisation
voilà du pouvoir mais certaines voix
critiquent aussi difficile à dire la
part de la gauche radicale de ces
manifestions qui deviennent violents ça
vous le niez aujourd'hui vous qui
connaissez bien le terrain est ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous excluez
totalement parce que c'est aussi une
partie de la france qui pense à aussi de
surveillance quand on allume son poste
de télé qu'on voit ces violences soyons
très clairs les linda kebab ou pas
spécialement connu pour être une scène
capitaliste syndicat policier laxistes
ou d'extrême gauche
le dit elle même on les dit black block
y aurait beaucoup à dire déjà fait des
émissions sujet je fais pas ouvrir tous
les tiroirs les 10 black blocks les
hommes en noir en tout cas qui sème le
bazar dans les manifestations sont
parfaitement identifiés par les forces
de l'ordre et par les autorités on sait
qu'ils sont etc
on les laisse faire on ouvre grand les
vannes d'une manifestation on les
referment et on laisse les éléments les
plus radicaux s'agiter ça ne s'annonce
actu les mouvements sociaux ça pense le
pouvoir pense-t-il ça discrédite les
mouvements sociaux et pour partie c'est
réussi sauf que finalement par
capillarité les gens qui voient non
seulement ça mais qui voit aussi des
buts il ait des blessés le fait de
déclarer une manifestation de ne pas
déclarer on arrive toujours au même
résultat
et quand vous avez les éléments les plus
radicaux qui sont pas du tout ni défilé
jaunies des grévistes mais qui sont là
et jean sébastien ferjou et osons de le
rappeler ça ne date pas de gilet jaune
on a déjà vu ça lors de la loi travaille
par exemple avec monsieur valls avec des
gens qui venaient on sait pas d'où ni
comment et avec une répression très
sévère donc ces gens là ils sont laissés
bien tranquillement
donc effectivement il y a des éléments
radicaux on les connaît on les laisse
faire on pour courir cette stratégie du
pourrissement
les mouvements sociaux et pour permettre
derrière de réprimer durement 10 envoyée
il ya mélenchon il ya l'extrême gauche à
l'écologie ce qu'était mais qui peut
être nuancer passage en laisse avec
cette analyse sur la question que vous
posez sur le préféré choqué par sa base
à l'époque je suis assez d'accord avec
ce que vous disais c'est pas lui qui est
le plus responsable
si c'est quand même lui la cheville
ouvrière des stratégies qui peuvent être
mises en oeuvre la stratégie la souris
siens sur la place d'italie ont dû
retour des gilets jaunes je pensais
quand même particulièrement contestable
mais moi j'avais été choqué par sa
phrase nous ne sommes pas dans le même
qu'en s'adressant à une manifestante ce
je ne pense pas que ce soit
éventuellement un ministre aurait pu
peut-être le dire parce qu'il ya un côté
politique et un ministre peut se
présenter ou se représenter devant une
élection où sa responsabilité être
engagée au parlement de la part d'un
haut fonctionnaire de l'état je trouve
ça choquant de dire nous ne sommes pas
dans le même camp du préfet l'allemand
n'a pas être dans un camp il a assuré le
maintien de l'ordre sans a priori
prendre parti d'ailleurs dans le conflit
politique et se joue derrière ses enjeux
ses enjeux de maintien de l'ordre
maintenant sur le pourrissement oui mais
là où je pense c'est à la fois ça marche
et ça ne marche pas c'est à dire que je
pense que ça me fait qu'accentuer la
crise de défiance c'est à dire que oui
peut-être ça déconsidère certains
mouvements sociaux et qu'il faut dire le
cherchant quelque sorte parce que c'est
quand même une stratégie du clivage la
violence je parle pas des manifestants
l'emmena mais on l'a vu encore la
dernière manifestation enfin celle du
jeudi 10 à 10 jours rue de la pépinière
il ya en quelque sorte de manifestation
et de cortège bien organisée puis un
prêt cortège où là il ya énormément de
violon et c'est une stratégie assez
classique de clivages pour justement
forcer les gens à choisir
quand le problème c'est que en général
les gouvernements essaient plutôt de
faire baisser la tension d'un cran et
que celui-là rentrer dans la danse
et donc c'est une espèce de redoutables
valse à deux en quelque sorte chacun
jouant ce côté c'est la stratégie des
terroristes alors bien sûr il s'agit pas
de la même je lance mais vous savez
c'est de dire 'voilà choisi cinq ans
parce que de toute façon ce qu'on vous
met sous le nez n'est pas acceptable je
pense que pour la majorité des français
choisissent ni l'un ni l'autre
ils sont juste effaré par ce qui se
passe parce qu'ils soutiennent les
policiers au sens où personne n'a envie
d'un pays où il n'y aurait plus de
maintien de l'ordre il y aurait plus de
policiers je tiens quand même apprécié
de la rencontre avec quelqu'un sur
atlantico qui s'appelle gilles klein qui
a fait mais je crois que vous en avez
fait beaucoup aussi didier qui a fait
toutes les manifestations où toutes les
manifestations des gilet jaune et la
plupart des manifestations liées au
conflit sur les retraites
il ya incontestablement des violences
policières incontestablement mais je
crois qu parce l'on dit mais il ya quand
même aussi en face de la part d'une
minorité de manifestants
une énorme violences malgré tout les
dents quand ça se joue sur des policiers
qui sont mal formés qui ont des
instructions politique peu claires
justement parce que ce n'est pas
toujours évident de savoir ce qu'ils
sont enfin ce qu'on attend d'eux gère
évidemment on attendait le maintien de
l'ordre une fois que vous avez dit ça ça
ne dit pas est ce qu'on laisse les gens
descendent les champs-elysées est ce
qu'on les laisse aller à tel endroit ou
pas donc voilà il ya toutes ces
responsabilités là que je dise cumulé je
crois qu'ils alimentent le climat
profondément délétère qui justement lors
de son discours à la police nationale
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a rappelé l'importance
de l' usage proportionné de la force lui
a juste et proportionnée de la force et
ce qui sépare la démocratie de
l'arbitraire ce qui distingue l'ordre et
la brutalité
c'est le fondement aussi de notre
confiance avec les français c'est
l'honneur de la police qui est en jeu on
ne fait pas de croche pied à l'éthique
sauf à s'abaisser à un baiser la police
à l'ats christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur qui semble tenir malgré
toutes les polémiques
qu'est ce qui fait que christophe
castaner soit encore là didier maïsto le
problème de
de ce gouvernement sans le vouloir lui
faire injure c'est que quand même comme
le disait tout à l'heure jean sébastien
il faut trouver des gens
il est assez faible techniquement je
dirais les personnalités qui en cours
qui entoure emmanuel macron élevé gérard
collomb qui est parti ne brillent pas
par leur technicité leurs capacités leur
charisme sur le champ du régalien c'est
quand même assez assez c'est triste donc
qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce gouvernement
en fait caca fait emmanuel macron il a
pris un peu de l air un peu de paix s
finalement c'est un peu le fond de cumul
qu'il est allé chercher parce que allait
aller chercher monsieur castanet rock
était 4e couteau au parti socialiste ou
d'autres je vais pas leur faire injure
enfin il fallait faire le en même temps
il fallait faire la république en marche
et essayer d'avoir un peu de droite et
de gauche
ma totale on voit que nous avons des
gens complètement dépassés qui ne sont
pas à la hauteur de leurs fonctions et
d'ailleurs pour finir là-dessus on parle
beaucoup de mots de techniques de
maintien de l'ordre etc
le problème c'est d'abord un problème
politique c'est à dire qu'on met on fait
faire à la police la police à les former
ou mal formés d'ailleurs mais pour faire
du maintien de l'ordre
pas pour répondre à une politique ou à
essayer d'en l'imposer or aujourd'hui on
voit que la seule réponse que ce soit
aux avocats aux médecins envoyés dans
des hôpitaux dans les eaux professeurs
aux grévistes quels qu'ils soient du
service public du service privé dans les
écoles partout qu'est-ce qu'on fait dès
qu'il ya une contestation d'envoi la
police on met les gens en garde à vue ou
alors de façon préventive on les met en
prison les interroger le lendemain puis
on les fait partir san mames un rappel à
la loi
c'est pour ça que je parle de régime on
est passé quand même dans autre chose
dans un régime
j'aime pas bien où je suis d'accord
c'est peut-être avec un certain nombre
de policiers
le terme notamment des d'alexandre
l'envoi de violences policières moi je
préfère parler de violence politique de
violence d'état parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous en sommes là et les policiers ne
sont que les instruments de cette
violence d'état et il ya beaucoup de
policiers qui sont jd jeu
je sais ça paraît incongru aujourd'hui
on en a eu sur 7 mois j'en rencontre
plein tous les jours je pense que
jean-sébastien aussi alors il ya aussi
les policiers qui sont comme d'accord
avec voilà la tête par dont la stratégie
du maintien de leur maman on écoute et
un loïc travers secrétaire national
adjoint de la section ile-de-france du
syndicat de police alliance
le vrai débat c'est qu'il y a une vraie
montée de violence que ce soit par le
biais ou de black blocks ou deux
personnes qui sont radicalisées ou des
personnes et biens qui simplement
viennent piller certains magasins qui
vient de se faire plaisir et bien ces
phénomènes la de bande ou pas d'ailleurs
que les policiers essaient d'enrayer
avec des techniques qui sont
effectivement extrêmement précises qui
sont pour le moment est clairement
techniquement juridiquement adapté il y
à de nombreux propos depuis quelques
semaines qui dit ben voilà que la police
ne doit plus utiliser les lacrymogènes
elle doit plus utiliser la matraque
télescopique elle ne doit pas utiliser
l'étranglement
elle ne doit plus utiliser le placage
ventrale un moment il faut bien qu'il
nous reste des techniques pour
interpeller les gens violents
on va pas finir en tutu avec une fleur à
la main pour interpeller des gens qui
s'en prennent à nos collègues et qui
n'ont qu'une envie de blesser gravement
voire de tuer jean sébastien ferjou
c'est vrai que ce policier il exprime
aussi la voie de voilà peut-être d'une
partie de l'opinion française parce
qu'on peut lui répondre
moi je comprends parfaitement ce qu'il
exprime passe comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure c'est une partie qui se
joue à deux soeurs que je suis d'accord
avec ce que disait didier maistre sur la
stratégie de mélange d'incompétence
technique ou de compétences faible
disons technique sur les sujets liés au
maintien de l'ordre et de stratégie
politique mais en face il ya quand même
des gens qui ne croient pas à la
démocratie représentative sire que les
intrusions dans les locaux de la cfdt
ou alors vouloir aller empêcher monsieur
m'a constatant leur empêcher d'aller au
théâtre ça paraît un peu ridicule comme
ça mais enfin quand on vit dans ce
climat là où la démocratie ne soit plus
possible des gens qui contestent la
légitimité de sa présence mais non je
suis désolé malgré tout monsieur macron
a été élu y aura des élections dans deux
ans
les gens qui ne sont pas d'accord même
ceux qui luttent qui contestent le
principe de la réforme des retraites
comprendre on passe dans notre sujet
mais enfin de 60 va s'appliquer dans
très longtemps il y aura des élections
bien avant ça s'ils sont persuadés de
détenir une majorité ils peuvent très
bien miser sur les élections suivantes
je pense qu'elle reste une
responsabilité aussi non pas
nécessairement des gens qui sont dans la
rue mais des responsables politiques
parfois qui soutiennent ce genre de
mouvement et qui en l'air de considérer
qu'il est normal de remettre en cause la
démocratie représentative ce n'est pas
parce que monsieur macron où son
gouvernement sont moins représentatifs
qu'on a connu enfin que dans ce qu'on a
pu connaître dans des périodes
antérieures mais tout simplement ce que
je vous disais c'est la crise de
défiance convient de toute façon demain
on fait des élections personne ne sera
follement représentatif
parce que la société est fracturée et
donc de toute façon ce qui les rend
placements ci tentait il existe une
alternative politique dans des élections
mm macro mais ça fait un peu partie du
problème aussi seraient eux aussi
vraisemblement très mal perçu moi je
crois pas qu'il faille jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain je crois démocratie
représentative et il faut savoir en
défendre les principes
maintenant quand la police est la seule
arme qui reste par un gouvernement pour
se maintenir au pouvoir même si c'est un
peu abusé parce qu'on n'est plus dans
cette situation là on a été probablement
un peu pendant l'été dernier c'est
complexe et je trouve particulier de la
part du président de la république ou
des ministres de l'intérieur de se
situer un peu en observateur extérieur
quand ils font des commentaires sur
l'emploi de la violence par la police il
me semble que quand même des éléments
dont nous disposons tous ils les ont
depuis maintenant des mois et que arrivé
comme ça en jambes quand même c'est un
peu dommage
voilà je trouve ce ne sont pas des
commentateurs ils sont responsables de
la politique est mise en oeuvre et le
cas échéant ils sont responsables je
parle pas de lan policiers qui mettrait
les plombs dans un instant d'énervement
je sais pas quoi ou bref mais ils sont
responsables
globalement du climat de violence qui
s'est passé dans ces manifestations
didier mais il se reconnaît votre avis
effectivement sur ces violences
policières mais sur ce que disait jean
sébastien ferjou sur voilà cette partie
peut-être des manifestants qui remettent
en cause la démocratie représentative
est ce qu'il est normal effectivement
d'aller soulever un président de la
république et au théâtre un samedi soir
avec son épouse
est ce que ça vous semble légitime
je sais pas si c
victime ou normal je sais pas ce qu'est
la norme en tout cas ce que je sais
c'est que ce président ce président a
écrit un livre intitulé révolution
il a dit lui-même c'est moi le
responsable qui viennent me chercher
on l'a dit lui-même les gens qui ne sont
rien les illettrés les factieux les
séditieux ça fait beaucoup quand on est
président de la république on doit pas
opposer les uns aux autres une catégorie
de français à une autre et donc si vous
voulez au bout d'un an au bout de
quatorze mois comme rien ne se passe les
gens lui disent chiche on va venir te
chercher je dis pas que c'est bien sauf
que c'est pas je dis pas de l'évidence
est ce sont des gens les manifestants
ambiguïté les normes et les manifestants
on me disait les gens mais juste sonar
mais les français n'y a quand même remis
chaque fois un euro dans la machine
il a un petit peu excité pensant être
évité un peut être un peu au dessus que
ça en disant vous allez voir moi je suis
assez d'accord avec vous de jeudi serait
facile de la démocratie ne se divise pas
c'est toujours sur les mauvais exemples
c'est comme la ville verte et
d'expression il faut se battre pour la
liberté d'expression quand quelqu'un dit
quelque chose de choquant juste de la
mer également d'être défendent les
institutions y compris quand celui qui
en est le titulaire comme les madden
macron mais pas nécessairement à la
hauteur de la finance je suis pleinement
non mais c'est simplement pour répondre
ça c'est vrai en théorie je dis
simplement que c'est un président qui
est disruptif comme il l'a voulu ainsi
lui il a dit mme emna de l'aliment que
le fait qu'il était révolutionnaire etc
il ne cesse d'attaquer les gens si on
reprend le florilège de toutes ces
petites phrases de lui de 5,2 de tout
son gouvernement etc
quand vous avez la porte parole qui dit
je souhaite bonne chance aux grévistes
ce matin je prends ma voiture de
fonction etc etc
c'est quand même un moment le mépris si
vous voulez s'ajoutant au mépris
s'ajoutant aux dénis et s'ajoutant
finalement au mutisme absolu parce que
je rappelle que le gilet jaune dont
jamais été reçue d'une manière difficile
et mesure les 10 milliards il ya eu des
mesures tout de même sur les mesures
à mesure non les mesures budgétaires il
faut regarder le plan de financement de
la sécurité sociale
la mobilisation a un petit peu baissé à
ce moment là c'est ma mort ok très bien
ce que je dis simplement c'est que là ce
président là s'est comporté d'une
manière quand même belliqueuse c'est un
belliciste c'est un combattant très bien
il en assume les conséquences je dis pas
que c'est bien joli pack je suis pas
dans le drame dans un ordre moral non
mais déjà il n'y a pas de l'ingestion de
politique parce que la violence c'est un
peu ce que j'ai fleuret toute heure la
violence vient aussi de là la
responsabilité elle est peut-être celle
de monsieur macron qui effectivement a
pu commettre un certain nombre d'erreurs
qu'il a lui-même reconnu d'ailleurs je
sais pas si sa lampe est vraiment de
continuer à les connaître
enfin bref il a semblé être conscient du
côté arrogant méprisant au provocateur
qu'il pouvait avoir
mais dans une démocratie il faut qu'il
ya une opposition qui se montre à la
hauteur et là le drame français à
l'heure actuelle c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de position qui parviennent
véritablement a structuré ou à pâte une
alternative crédible parce qu il ya d
autres positions ont fait 9 actuellement
on en a toujours
marine le pen on peut voir les
républicains qui reste le premier parti
d'opposition du pays si on regarde en
vendée u
la france a soumises d'autres mais ils
n'arrivent pas à formuler une réponse mm
macro qui sembleraient à tirer derrière
elle une majorité de français est
largement ça vient aussi la violence
vient aussi de là parce que dans une
démocratie quand la démocratie paraît
bloquée que certaines catégories de
population l'impression qu'elles seront
exclues du pouvoir de toute façon parce
que les haies sont à leur permettront
jamais battant de les solutions qu'elle
souhaite à ce moment là il ya toujours
de la violence qu'est-ce qui s'extrait
alors rapidement
il ya quand même un problème sinon
sébastien parler de démocratie
représentative
il faut respecter évidemment il a été
élu tout le respect que c'est légitime
et je suis pas un factieux très bien il
faut quand même se poser la question de
la cette représentativité de la
démocratie qui est quand même
à l'agonie puisque je rappelle que en
nombre en il a fait de 25 25% des voix
au premier tour mais 18 % d'inscrits
c'est à dire que sur 100 personnes
il ya 82 personnes qui n'ont pas voté
pour emmanuel macron non c'est pas
propre à emmanuel macron on l'a vécu
avec françois hollande
on l'a vécu avec jacques chirac et ses
allées fier de tout ce qui faisait là
encore moins de voix via une
balkanisation une atomisation total de
la vie politique française il n'y a pas
de solution
donc c'est pour ça que s'est exprimé le
droit de nous alors le 2 allée vers
mettre le curseur ne dit pas
complètement mais pousser le curseur
vers plus de démocratie participative de
l'initiative citoyenne et c'est que les
gens reprennent un petit peu emballant
souveraineté et puissent avoir les
manettes pas surtout aimé avoir plus de
référendum plus de participation je
pense qu'on peut revivifiée revitaliser
comme ça la démocratie quand même il va
rester sur le à ces malades
merci dd mr mercier jean sébastien
ferjou d'avoir été avec nous on reste